There is a very interesting new poll from
The Wall Street Journal about this upcoming
election.
And it's interesting not because it says Biden
is ahead by nine.
We have many polls that say that.
And it may be true if we see the margin of
error, Biden plus nine might really mean Biden
plus two.
That's nothing new here.
What's interesting about this new poll is
that it breaks down Trump vs. Biden all along
a number of different voting groups.
And when you look at it, when you slice and
dice the electorate, you see that Donald Trump
is winning among men, barely 47 43.
That's interesting because Republicans tend
to win among men by more than four points.
We'll talk about that more on Friday.
Trump is winning among.
White voters, barely 49 to 47.
And Donald Trump is winning among people with
high school or less education by a huge margin,
nearly 20 points.
Trump is up 54 36 among what are colloquially
called the uneducated.
Now, every other group, every single other
group.
Donald Trump is losing.
Some examples include black voters.
Biden's up 88 to 80.
Brutal people with postgraduate degrees.
Biden is up 65 to 28.
People who are college graduates.
Biden is up 61 31.
Among women and among Hispanic voters, Biden
has 57 percent support.
And importantly, among independents, Biden
is up 24, 49 to 25.
Now, when you see this, you have to consider
whether some of these things are cadge, are
causal or correlated.
So, for example, the more education you have,
the more likely you are to vote Biden.
We see that right.
High school or less.
Biden has 36 supports, sir, 36 percent support.
If you have some college.
Biden has 47 percent support.
Few graduated college.
Biden support goes up to 61.
And if you have a post graduate degree, Biden
is up even higher to 67.
I believe this is causal.
I don't think this is merely correlation.
Donald Trump's campaign has been objectively
one of lying to voters about things he could
never possibly do as president.
And many people fell for voting for Trump.
That's the right terminology.
Not everybody, but many people did.
More education makes you less likely to vote
for a candidate like Trump.
And I would argue for Republicans more broadly.
So in this case, if you want people to vote
for Trump, you actually benefit from hurting
education, not funding public schools, not
dealing with the student lending crisis.
So on and so forth.
So you really have to look at this stuff and
understand the link to campaign strategy and
platforms.
There are ideologically based positions that
politicians will take or parties will go in
the direction of.
But there are also self-preservation directions.
Are Republicans against education because
some of them see it as anti religious indoctrination?
Sure.
Yeah.
That exists among some right wing voters.
But a lot of right wing voters recognize that
the more educated people are, the less likely
they are to vote for them.
And so that's really important to look at.
Now, one last word of caution.
Biden plus nine in this poll, two and a half
months before the election is exactly where
Hillary Clinton was in this poll two and a
half months before the 2016 election.
That's all that needs to be said.
Trust nothing other than your ability to vote
and to convince others to vote.
That's it.
We are coming up on the David Pakman shows,
15th anniversary on August.
Twenty third on that day.
We will be sending out to everybody on our
newsletter a huge membership special.
The goal being to have our best month ever
for new memberships this month because it
is our 15th anniversary to be notified of
that special on the twenty third.
Simply subscribe to my newsletter for free
at David Pakman dot com.